who are you I'm no one
I was raised to do one thing but I've
got nothing to fight for
nothing will stand in our way
I'm finish
what you started
there are stories about what happened
it's true
Oh
the dark side
Jedi
the real
the force it's calling to you
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Star Wars trailer breakdown
everybody let's freak out this is the
last big final trailer we'll probably a
lot more footage but this is one of the
last big huge trailers high fives anyone
that was able to buy a ticket on
Fandango before it crashed like a Star
Destroyer I just I barely made it in
under the wire you should be able to buy
tickets pretty soon though they should
they should fix the issue it's just that
everybody's 'red online ticketing don't
don't worry everyone will get to see it
so here we go in heads up I'm actually
I'm doing a special giveaway just
because this is so freaking awesome I'm
gonna give away two free IMAX movie
passes slice like a $40 value all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video
what more details at the end of this
order the big time I will totally not
judge you if you started crying like
whenever the Star Wars music you started
playing but this is all about the force
awakening it's calling to you just let
it in so it sounds like we actually
heard Lupita's character I didn't
actually see her but it opens on Ray's
character I know a lot of you sounded
disappointed that Ray wasn't holding a
lightsaber and in the poster but I do
think that she's force sensitive is a
reason she's holding her staff parallel
to kylo Ren here but I think in these
opening scenes with her the voices we're
hearing are Lupita's character Maz
Kanata talking to Ray I know a lot of
people are thinking that Lupita's
character might be the one to give the
protagonist anakin skywalker's
lightsaber that we've seen in previous
trailers but i think it's really
interesting them then putting her at the
beginning of this trailer in what she's
doing here tells you about what's going
on she's investigating the Star
Destroyer wreckage from the battle of
jakku so it's almost like she's
rediscovering the past and that's
another big theme in the trailer all the
stories you've heard they're true you
know Han Solo is just saying the Jedi
the dark side the Empire all those
things that happened 30 years ago
they're totally true it does make you
wonder what the Imperial propaganda
machine has turned into and it's just
really icing on the cake the fact that
she says I'm no one it just makes you
think of Arya Stark and Game of Thrones
she is kind of like the Arya Stark of
this movie Finney looks like he starts
out with the first order like he has a
crisis of conscience he just doesn't
know what he's supposed to be doing with
his life I don't know what my purpose is
that's a big theme of this movie to
these new characters recognizing their
purpose so he crashes on jakku and
there's a disturbance in the force we
actually we heard that in the last
trailer too talking to kylo Ren's
character have you felt it this is just
awesome seeing this close
up of his mask if you haven't bought one
for Halloween now's the time to do it
but you can clearly see that he has gone
and scavenged the remains of Darth
Vader's armor so he's talking to the
helmet like he feels like Darth Vader
was doing something really awesome and
he wants to continue the mission
here's Poe Dameron who it looks like
they've captured and are interrogating
here's the Star Destroyer wreckage again
maybe after they've rescued the new
characters this just looks so much more
awesome inside the Millennium Falcon now
that they've added a little bit of CG
most of this is all practical though I
know everybody's like really appreciates
that they built a real set
han Solo speechify in the past punch it
Chewie kylo Ren with a bunch of
first-order troopers I don't think that
these are the Knights of Ren that's the
organization that he got his name from
like he took that name I don't know if
that'll still be a thing when the movie
picks up this looks like it's after Finn
has joined the resistance it kind of
reminds you of a new hope when Han Solo
and Luke Skywalker are saying their last
goodbyes before they go to assault the
Death Star
like good luck kid this is Han Solo
looking like he might be taking them to
some sort of Jedi Temple maybe he's
taking them to Luke Skywalker that'd
actually be really awesome I'm not
expecting to see him in any of these
clips supposedly he's just going to be a
bigger character in Episode eight than
he is in Episode seven Captain phasma
looking fabulous JJ Abrams actually said
that she's like his favorite new
character so I'm interested to see how
many people love Captain phasma she's
probably going to become like the Boba
Fett person of the movie just like that
one quirky character that everyone wants
to cosplay as this looks like someone
really important his diet so everyone
theorycraft I think it's going to be a
main character but it might be a new
main character it might not be one of
the original ones she gets real this ice
planet is supposed to be where the
Starkiller base is and it might even be
inside the planets core like so big that
the planet itself hides it the poster
makes it look like it's another Death
Star like it's just like an external
thing that floats around but it might be
inside the planet too we don't we don't
know yet more awesome battles this will
all be playable in video games so if you
guys want to play these don't worry you
will get the chance
Princess Leia for the first time on the
resistance base and lightsaber battle
gets real so I will go ahead and
say that I do not think that Darth Vader
is going to be a big thing in this movie
a lot of people were wondering there
were their theories that he might be
resurrected he might appear in some way
if he appears it would be in a flashback
and I'm not
affecting flashbacks kylo ren's
character just wants to pick up where
darth vader left off
even though Luke Skywalker was able to
redeem Vader and Vader kind of changed
his plans in the fourth quarter deep in
the fourth quarter but it is freaking
awesome footage everybody let's freak
out and we watch this like ten more
times what I'm going to do tomorrow is
post a Q&A for this we're all announced
the giveaway winner and congratulations
to my reverse flash ring giveaway winner
John Quinn you in a reverse flash ring
be sure to private message me on the
back end of my channel so I get your
contact info so everybody rewatch the
trailer a couple more times I'll put a
link in the description and I'll see you
tomorrow for the QA video so while you
guys wait for everything to post you can
click here for all my Star Wars footage
and you can click here to catch up with
Captain America civil war trailer for
that coming really soon - thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tomorrow
me me me me